Now it's your turn to setup the client ID's, so
that you can use the My Profile page in your Conference
Central application. After you get everything hooked up, you'll find
that more and more of the web pages start to work,
as you add more functionality in the coming exercises. So
I'm just going to go over the things that you need to
do to hook up the web UI to the backend
API. going to need to get the client ID. To do that,
just go to the developer's console and in your
web, in your client ID for web application, you
can get your client ID. And then you're going to
set the web client ID in Constants.java so that your
end points API knows which client IDs are allowed
to access it. Then you're also going to add the client
ID in app.js so that your web UI can
identify itself properly when it goes through the authentication process.
Then you're going to need to make sure that
the developer email and the product name are set
in the consent screen. And then also in
the developers console, you're going to need to set
the JavaScript cross origin so that the client
application knows which URL's are allowed to access it
when they run JavaScript. So this you do
in the developer's console. These two are in code.
And these again, you do back in
the Developer Console. So after you've gone through
these steps, then deploy your app. And you
could do it on localhost or on appspot.
And then go to, to My Profile page, and test it. And as you go through
each of these steps, come here and just check off the step, as you do them.